who is using chat GPT every day
whoa that's 60 of you how many people
are using it every week
at least once a week that's probably the
remaining how many people are not using
it every day or every week yet
oh
okay they must be the swedes I guess
it wouldn't be
wouldn't be Norwegians okay
so
let's kick this off
I actually did this image
10 minutes before we started with
mid-journey that's how clever I am
uh let's run this but I don't want the
duplication
alrighty alrighty let's kick off
um
my name's Adam kogan and this talk that
I have written is called rules to better
Chachi BT and I have been speaking at
NDC for so long I've been speaking for
at Microsoft conferences for over 20
years now
and this is the coolest API I have ever
come across it's really going to change
everything we do it's phenomenal
I've structured my talk in this manner I
have just gonna get you up to speed with
some news uh there's a lot of news in
fact unfortunately this talk will be out
of date in a couple of weeks
everything's changing a lot I wrote this
talk on 3.5 and then everything had to
be Rewritten for four
then I want to get you up to speed with
prompt engineering how many people here
are prompt engineers
okay four okay there'll be more soon
then I want to get you up to speed with
the GPT service and then I want to talk
to you about embeddings and the rules
bot that we wrote and talking about the
future we'll do a bit of pontificating
so this is me I'm a Microsoft Regional
director
uh there's a few of us in Australia
there's a few in every country around
the world
I'm the also the Chief Architect at ssw
we are we have offices in Australia
China and Strasbourg France
now
um I also blog at adamkogan.com
since
um I've been coming to Norway getting to
know the Norwegian culture uh Troy hunt
and I got Jacob to take the conference
to Australia and we love the NDC
conference it's the best Microsoft
conference we have
a lot of fun and the Viking culture has
taken over
there is a photo just two weeks ago us
uh half our office there dressed up
that's sold Norwegian oh uh
that photo will be deleted from the
recording so you only just got to see
that one
I spent a lot of my time writing these
rules I wrote the first several hundred
by myself and now we have a team getting
close to 100 now Engineers running these
rules all the time about.net about
um apis how to run projects how to do
scrum how to everything everything we do
is in here
and I'm going to talk about that as we
go but I have one of the guys in the
office just recorded this to convince
you guys to come and visit us so
awesome
[Music]
to see you down in The Lucky Country
welcome to Australia let me show you
around I reckon yous are gonna love it
here let's take a gander
from Bunnings to Bondi they entry to
Desert to a really big Rock Australia
has something for everyone you could
visit the opera house and take a walk
along Sydney Harbor enjoy our unique
Wildlife while exploring our national
parks then eat them
go surfing in the Sunshine Coast or
catch a tram in Melbourne's vibrant
nightlife whatever you choose we'll be
ready to throw another snag on the
barbie for years
Australia
take a pun
[Music]
all right thank you Luke for that
all right so um if you want we have this
system on all our videos on our YouTube
videos that you can scan this you get
the uh the app and at the end of this
talk I'll give you another QR code you
get a thousand points we send out a lot
of these bands and other prizes
so let's jump into the news the first
piece of news is our favorite tool
uh the chat gbt bot has get is getting
all these extensions so it wasn't able
to give you an answer before you know a
couple years ago when the model was
built so it was two years old data now
if you install uh this browsing
extension you can say who won the Oscar
and it will tell you this year's answer
in addition you'll see a whole bunch of
these coming one is called the code
interpreter if you install that and then
you upload say a CSV file or a python
script it will turn it into this so a
plain CSV file will turn into a chart
and a little summary okay
um
how many people have watched the stuff
that came out of build just in the last
two days
okay only a few of us okay so probably
less than two or three percent of the
room
um
everything is changing everything's in
Windows every office user making a word
doc you'll be using chat gbt or you'll
be using the AI Services inside office
making a PowerPoint will be Auto
generated as a coder where we have
co-pilot and it's doing a lot of the
work for us now
I'll quickly just show you what I'm
talking about just so you you get a very
quick idea I can never remember how
to get the the item from the rack
uh now that's not what we want here but
if we give it a little bit more
information like this oh yeah it's on
the body whenever I'm working in react I
tend so whether you're in C sharp or
you're in react you're just typing
comments and the code is being put put
there I forget things like how do I add
an inline style to like an H1 tag but
what you can do is just add a comment
with the control slash here and just say
an H1 with inline style you don't even
have to spell it right and there you go
and it's super helpful in CSS I can
never remember how to highlight a list
item when it so he's uh just putting a
comment here he's looking at the output
here and he wants to what does he want
to do highlight a list item a user Mouse
is over it okay copilot knows or things
like I can never remember how to how to
get rid of the bullets
so he wants to get rid of these bullets
now he's added a rollover he's just
putting a comment in the list again you
don't have to spell this correctly and
they're gone and finally the thing that
nobody can remember
horizontally and vertically Center this
there it's it's centered all right so
you're going to get a lot of help with
any of that stuff that you're doing it's
very impressive we're right at the cusp
where most people aren't using these
tools where you can really do like half
an hour of work and you've done more
than you would normally do in a day and
you can have a break right but you
wouldn't do that
but you could
now inside Microsoft they keep talking
about the developer acceptance rate they
want the more and more of the
suggestions they give you to be accepted
and they keep looking at all these stats
um
what they're doing now because you know
when you like GPT is essentially a
Transformer that works out what we just
said and picks the next word it's really
just an autocomplete uh it's that is
minimizing what it does but that's the
guts of it now inside code it has been
looking at what code we had and
suggesting code we should do from here
but what they're doing now is something
called fim fill in the Middle where
they're looking at the code there and
the code here and it's getting more and
more accurate and their developers are
taking the suggestions more and more so
you can read that article it talks a lot
about all that I think it's pretty cool
if you're not a c-sharp guy then you
might be more interested in code
Whisperer from AWS you can look down the
pros and cons like if you're a c-sharp
guy here you're going to care about uh
co-pilot more if you're an AWS Lambda
guy you'll care more about Amazon how
many people here would care more about
uh Copilot
okay that looks to be 90 of the room how
many people would care more about code
Whisperer
poor W AWS they don't have anyone in
Norway that likes them
that is amazing I didn't expect that
answer all right uh there's stuff Beyond
coding and office knowledge workers
they're the data guys and I'm going to
tell you this you know Microsoft bought
synapse uh and if you look at what
they've just announced in the last day
this is probably going to be seen you
know back in time when we're in the
future that this is as big as when
Microsoft bought SQL Server right I know
some of you saying what they bought SQL
Server yeah Microsoft buy a lot of
things that are cool so they bought
synapse it's now called fabric fabric is
bloody cool like just
uh I'll just quickly get you up to speed
with this but basically they're trying
to get you to have a data Lake per per
organization and you can read all this
it's pretty amazing uh I could I'll just
play one little bit so you can see it
next Generation AI in Microsoft fabric
empowers you to unlock the full
potential of your
with co-pilot integrated into every data
experience Microsoft fabric lets you use
natural language to bring your data to
life from integrating data to writing
code to finding insights and creating
reports new transformative AI
experiences work alongside you every
step of the way so you can stay focused
on getting value from your data copilot
helps turn your words into Data flows
and data pipelines so you can
intelligently integrate data from
anywhere when writing code co-pilot
automatically suggests code an entire
function in real time and copilot can
guide you to create machine learning
models to unlock insights in your data
by chatting with co-pilot
explore your data to create stunning
reports discover insights and summarize
your data into easy to understand text
narratives for sharing with copilot you
can turn insight into action with
triggers that monitor your data and
notify uses can even create your own
custom natural language experiences that
combine Azure open AI models and your
organization's data and easily publish
your Creations as plugins and with your
data and fabric copilot provides
insights and answers everywhere easily
publish your do you see this you type a
question and it generates the SQL okay
anyone can be a SQL Server programmer
now Creations as plugins and with your
data in fabric co-pilot provides
insights and answers everywhere won't
get started most importantly Microsoft
cloud runs on trust all right enough of
that but I think that gives you a
gives you a bit of an idea how many
people here are data people data guys
so almost no one probably five percent
how many people think this is bloody
cool
almost everyone yeah it's uh yeah the
stuff coming out is phenomenal
now there was some talk here about how
Microsoft disbanded their uh their
safety team their AI safety team uh big
news
um and obviously this stuff was received
poorly they have clarified what what
happened that they decide not to have
one big team that did this don't you
love all these pop-up ads
I thought like you guys in the EU
stopped all this
uh obviously not very well now
um it basically says look we got rid of
one monster team and that we decided to
do it since everybody's doing Ai and
there's so many teams we allocated all
those people across all the teams so
it's exactly what we do with privacy
security accessibility they all have uh
individuals in those teams and that's
how they're doing it now
thought I might tell you that
and in case you thought gpt5 was coming
it sounds like it's not coming for a
farewell Sam Altman is making sure that
nobody gets any more freaked out than we
already are and he says we haven't even
done any training on it so don't worry
about it
let's get into prompt engineering prompt
engineering we go to chat GPT and we
start typing away what is NDC well it's
a Norwegian developers conference blah
blah blah blah okay
um
oh in fact there's a cooler way
you should all install the shortcut on
your phone
and you can install a shortcut and I can
just say hey Siri
foreign
just started calling someone I don't
know why
GPT mode
oh I've turned off the speaker so I
can't hear anything
that would be why
hey Siri
GPT mode
works perfectly
hey Siri
GPT mode
what are the top 10 happiest countries
in the world and be brief
one moment
must be using gpt4
working on that
here this is faster in Australia
one Finland it has a comprehensive
social welfare system and high levels of
trust and equality two Denmark it has a
strong that wasn't very good
it's nice to have one's work appreciated
GPT mode
what are the top 10 happiest countries
in the world and be brief
one moment
working on that
[Music]
I'm having trouble with the connection
I'll try again later all right okay as
you can see that's awesome uh
but uh I usually enjoy that uh at dinner
parties it's fun
anyway all right
now
um
you can go to the fridge and say look
I've got chicken asparagus and tomatoes
what can I make and it will just tell
you what's there you can say hey I hit
this error what do I do with this null
reference exception now I want you to
understand this is not the right way to
ask questions okay you don't say how do
I fix this bug and paste it okay you've
if you want good answers you've got to
be a good prompt engineer and say act as
a senior software engineer how do I fix
this when running my c-sharp project in
visual studio and then give it that
you'll get way better answers be aware
just recently act as sometimes turns
into funny mode it thinks it's being
um here it's asking you to be humorous
so then you have to say I am a senior
engineer so you know you'll work these
things out also GPT is heavily
influenceable
and so you don't say isn't it true that
electric cars are better than you know
gasoline cars you have to say something
like what are the benefits and drawbacks
of electric versus gasoline okay just be
never influence it it's very easy so
basically you've got to know role
you know the result that you want I want
five email subjects because I'm about to
send an email to a lot of very important
people across the entire company the
email is to tell all the developers at
the company about a ux problem with
search and we want them to watch this
YouTube video I've recorded and give me
some feedback
and then you say make it less than 50
characters that's the constraint so it's
a little bit like when we learned
select from where you know join it's
you've got to know the this style of
prompting because this is going to mean
that you know you saw I created an image
before the presentation and I have never
used Photoshop right a marketing
assistant is essentially going to be a
prompt engineer a Content writer the
same thing social media manager graphic
design is there they're going to be
prompt Engineers like you can use daily
mid Journey or stable diffusion they're
all phenomenal
sonographer is gone even pop stars are
just going to be prompt Engineers you
can just generate this stuff
okay software developers we're finished
and Woodworkers are going to remain
Woodworkers
okay
so I I went on to Australia's leading uh
job site and I typed in prompt engineer
and it said no matching search results
I was shocked I promise you in six
months time this is going to have
thousands
um look if I type in net developer like
a specific type you get a couple of
thousand jobs that prompt engineering is
going to be a big big thing so you need
to teach people to have a role you know
what am I I'm a GitHub actions expert so
you know tell me what I should do here
uh be careful to you know keep telling
it to be concise because it just Rambles
on I like it to answer in bullet points
or give me the top 10 or something if
you're getting it to do emails it's good
to say you know be professional be funny
I usually use you know be humorous
and you've got to be careful about
confidential information I don't know if
this is the right uh complete fix to the
whole thing but you know we're a
consulting company and we we want to use
it on all our projects so we just did
this
um and we and we sent it out to all our
clients that's you know we just add an
extra Clause use of AI Technologies you
authorize us to do this
in fact I could I don't need to read
that I could
I'm just getting used to this mouse
so read selection aloud the client
authorizes ssw to use such artificial
intelligence Technologies EG chat GPT as
ssw considers appropriate in the conduct
of the work
the client must notify ssw if it does
not wish ssw to so use in respect of any
of the work all right and let me tell
you and many did they notified us as you
will experience they want you to keep
working very slow which is fine if you
if you're on an hourly basis
now if you're the the best thing about
this is how it keeps context and you do
a bit and then you learn so you can say
you know create me a guide with a
headline teaser now create five
subtopics now add three techniques of
each so it keeps growing it as you keep
looking at it you know and we'll even
critique it for usability and and
correct itself after it's generated
um so all you can do I call this doing
super prompting I'm not sure what the
proper term is but um you just put it
all together in one go and then you get
your answer and you'll get better and
better at this and as soon as you do
this you just correct it
so I made these um these uh cheat sheets
which I'll give you at the end
um but I've got a whole lot of these
cheat sheets I put them in every one of
the toilets at ssw
I really did and um and then I create a
cheat sheet for Dev Edition so I've got
both of them for you
um and you can grab them at the end but
this is for writing code this for
debugging this for understanding code
documenting code and refactoring Etc so
it's uh you can you can grab it from the
URL down here or you can get physical
copies if you want all right
and we have a whole lot of these and
they all were generated from these rules
okay so I want to tell you my problem uh
like I'm using chat GPT all the time and
I think it's bloody awesome so I wanted
to work out what I could do to use all
these rules and get the benefits of chat
GPT so I went on this little
journey trying to integrate these and
I'm going to talk about all these but
these rules that we have
they're all um they're all here uh
they're just open sourced and there's
thousands of them
and
yeah we we have we have a whole bunch of
the the the company uh writing rules on
this okay and you can submit rules and
changes too
so let's get up to speed with the GPT
service not the not the bot the service
so it's a large language model what how
do we work out what it is well we say
Give Me Five Dot points on GPT it'll say
it's a Transformer it's it works it's
magic because it got heaps of text like
basically the whole internet
um
and it predicts the the next most
probable word not only does it do
language generation it does translation
and understanding so it's pretty
phenomenal now it is seven years old
did you know that feels like it just
came out a year ago
uh it's now owned 49 by Microsoft this
has got to be the deal of the century
like uh this is phenomenal and
we have the the chat bot which you won't
believe was written by one guy so they
have a whole team at open AI working on
this large language model they've got
Johnny in the corner doing some bot
which no one cared about no one thought
it was that going to be popular even Sam
Altman said oh I didn't even think it
was going to be popular when we released
it that's why we didn't do any social
media we didn't do anything we just put
it up there because they were releasing
3.5 which they thought wasn't that
awesome because they already had four
and so they threw it out there just to
see any feedback and wow it blew up
so let's talk about the API the best API
we've ever had it does natural language
processing image generation and speech
recognition what's the name of the model
here how many people know the name of
the model
few it's called gpt4 okay and what's the
name of the model for image generation
Dali and the one for speech recognition
whisper great all right so what you
should all do now is scan this QR code
because the more all these extensions
that are coming out you're going to need
your own API okay and you're gonna
um you're gonna need your own key to
plug into all these extensions and we're
going to use this little guy later but
when you scan that QR code you go to a
site you press create new secret key you
can give it a name whatever one you're
using at that time for example we'll say
ssw rules here you create the secret key
you copy this guy and we're going to use
it later
all right so one of the things that you
will decide if you're going to build
something like what I'm going to show
you inside your company you're either
going to ask them to all enter their key
to use gpt4 because gpt4 is more
expensive than GPT 3.5 it's about 30
times more expensive so it's substantial
and you're going to have to decide how
you so throughout a company I guess if
it's a rich company I know you you guys
are from Norway most of you you're
pretty rich or you used to be rich until
they all went to Switzerland didn't they
yeah but
but anyway
at least um some of the companies might
decide we're just going to pay for this
and let all our users not bother about
keys and but what you're going to find
is 3.5 is pretty bloody good as it is
maybe not good enough you'll make that
call we'll talk about that
so you're gonna you're either gonna ask
them for their key or you're going to
have code where you're using Azure ID
okay
so this is kind of the way we did it and
you'll see what I did later on but you
can use our key or you can put in your
key and use four okay
so these are the six things you're going
to need to know if you're going to build
a solution on this you're going to need
to know what hosting okay you got two
the API the tokens
temperature
and the playground and mucking around
with the system message
okay and embeddings
all right so you've got two choices are
you going to use openai.com
which runs on azure
or are you going to use azure's open AI
service which uh also runs on azure
and it's using open ai's models right
it's all but basically the same thing
backwards uh whichever one you choose
you're going to have the same experience
and you're going to you know fine tune
your models and you're going to try to
work out which one do I use now this is
a funny first question
that the billing is almost identical
it Azure is cheaper for very large
workloads and there's a there's a post
here I'll put here for you to to read
about it but it's cheaper for big ones
uh you're probably going to if you're a
dot-net person and you want to use like
the new get packages you'll get the
benefit of that so that would probably
be a good one if you're very familiar
with Azure virtual networks or Azure key
Vault or Azure monitor or Azure ID
you'll probably want the Azure option
okay Azure has a wait list
but open AI can get straight away but
only 3.5 and then you have to do a wait
list for four now 3.5
is very fast and stupid
okay four
is slow and expensive
but very solid okay so you're gonna but
there look I shouldn't say 3.5 is stupid
I should say it was super easy to
influence and gives you bogus answers
sometimes
which is annoying so you can say you
know what's the difference of open AI
versus so it's all embedded in in Bing
chat so you may as well switch how many
people have felt that they've switched
to Bing because they've got
um chat GPT built in
not many
maybe 10 percent ah well I think the
more that you use it the more you'll
realize that uh that benefit is huge but
then Google are doing good things with
Bart as well okay
uh
I would say like I've obviously used GPT
a lot more than bad but uh it seems
but it has good first impressions but uh
the more you use it it seems worse in
almost every way
okay but who knows anyway you've got
you've got these apis that you you've
got to know and love uh you know in the
request body you've got model messages
and I want to just drill down into the
messages because you've got to roll the
role is system user or assistant if you
are passing a message you type a message
that one of the happiest countries
you're passing it as a user and then the
response comes back is the assistant the
system bit is the magic am I going to
come to that but that is the default one
that's there that makes the messages
better okay make the responses better
and allows you know people to use it and
in your company just type very small
messages and they'll get a good answer
back
the other thing to be aware of is tokens
tokens is how much you can pass in and
get back
you'll start using this thing called a
token tester
token is essentially a word every word
is a token if you look closely there's a
many that are two see this interconnects
that one is three tokens uh you'll start
learning how this works but it's
essentially
four thousand words
now these four thousand tokens for 3.5
um raised to 8 000 for gpt4 and for the
32k version 32 000 tokens you can see
within you know within six months this
is gonna get big you know I can see a
future where you're passing in a gig you
know it these are these are growing
pretty quick
you've also then got to think about the
temperature what's the temperature
the temperature is if you look if you
use Bing and you ask a a question down
here you'll see this bit here see this
bit will drill into this this little guy
is more creative or more balanced or
more precise most of you will just leave
it at default but when you're wanting to
make a cool funny I don't know speech
for someone uh you can use more creative
and it gets gets fun uh those numbers
range from zero to two that you can pass
in and that would mean creative is two
balanced is one and more precise is zero
now if you start using it you'll you'll
learn very quickly that two
becomes ridiculous you know if you say
speakers uh write a happy birthday
message speak as a viking it becomes
nonsensical so we don't know what these
numbers are but you can guess it's
something around 1.8 1 and 0.2 you can't
get to the extremes now
as an example I just said what is Adam
Cogan from ssw doing today and it said
I'm sorry I can't find information what
his plans are for today he's the chief
Arctic this is W uh is there anything
else you'd like to know because it
doesn't know if you choose more balanced
it's almost the same what is he doing
today he will you know he's the Chief
Architect here he works on all these
type of solutions I don't know what he's
doing today what can I help you with
right if you say get creative it starts
uh saying look he's the Chief Architect
he works on custom solution he's one of
two Microsoft regional directors he
blogs at this he interviews for this TV
show I don't know exactly what he's
doing but he's based in Sydney so he
might be working on a project with his
team or clients or attending some events
he might be swimming at Bondo icebergs
anyways so it's gone off to different
sites and aggregating stuff and making
stuff up okay
now when you start using the Azure AI
Studio you'll see that it's broken down
into the setup the chat session and the
configuration you'll go straight for the
chat and you'll start typing these user
messages down here but I want you to
focus on this part this is the setup
and this setup is where you say hey
you know like if if this is a if you're
making a bot for a doctor it better be
serious right if you're if generally
inside a company you want it to be fun
depending on what type of
um you know Persona you want you need to
add a whole lot of reference data and
examples of what type of responses you
want like I want a URL or I want it in
bullet points or I you know I want a
certain formatting you know I want it in
table form so that's the system message
now when you're using the playground to
start testing this so we have this
concept in our company which is called a
V2 email as soon as somebody types an
email
and they've made a mistake this is for
new employees we just teach them that if
you made a mistake don't reply and say
oh sorry here's the attachment and by
the way I said that I was happy to do I
meant I was not happy I just forgot and
you know you know how people do that we
just teach them we just start again and
you do V2 right and you just put V2 at
the top and forget the other one now how
we just want them to write that and it
to work for that to work you really need
to make sure your system message is
right and you'll refine this so for
example we'll say you know we want
you're the bot okay you're friendly and
you're funny
um we want you to be
um
uh
uh you know you'll we'll come to this
but you set this all up via a database
okay and we'll get to this but the
important thing is the experience how do
I write a V2 email sometimes you'll need
a V2 email for two reasons for this or
this and here are what you need to do go
to your send items go resend blah blah
blah okay whatever instructions you have
and you go round and round and round you
keep playing with this until it's right
so in short right now you understand the
hosting options the API the tokens the
temperature and the playground right now
we have to talk about embeddings how
many people here are familiar with
embeddings
I've got about eight of several hundred
so not too many so this is this is the
problem I got to I wanted like everybody
comes to me because they can't find
Rules and Things and uh I'm not scalable
so I thought I want to combine chat GPT
with the wisdom of the rules
so I wanted it to work like this and
this is how it works how do I send a V2
email just a new employee it gives them
the answer and links off to the rule
okay so you're going to have an internet
full of stuff and you just want to be
able to have nice conversation now
obviously these type of things are going
to be existing on almost every site for
every business you're going to go to a
travel agent and if they don't have a
bot where you can quickly ask questions
I want to get a flight to the Canary
Islands
next month what have you got you know
you want quick answers you don't want to
be doing all the searching and stuff
so
um and that they'd click on that link
and they'd end up on the rule that's
that's the experience we're after
so let's talk about these embeddings all
right now these embeddings uh now by the
way this is how I would have done things
for the last 20 years I would just go to
Google Images find an image that kind of
represents what I'm thinking about I
want you to understand embeddings so I'd
go there and do this you know what I do
now it takes me about 20 seconds is I go
oh can you make me an image and I want
it to
do this very similar to what I'd put in
Google Images and I then say but I want
in these colors because I want in
certain company colors and stuff I'm
really happy I think this is awesome
we don't need any more graphic designers
anymore
so explain the concept of embeddings so
simply that an idiot could understand
not that I am one this merely
hypothetical
now I've put that in because
GPT seems to remember things all the
time so I don't want it to remember I'm
an idiot
so it then because this is a weird this
this embeddings is a bit unusual for us
imagine you've got a box of differently
shaped and colored Legos blah blah blah
it's kind of describing this you've got
shapes and you've got colors and you've
got this okay so you've got red over
here you've got blue over here you've
got squares now this isn't a very good
explanation of what embeddings are when
you get down it's very simple I also
made this thing give me a a picture of
1536 Dimensions uh and look look what I
got I'm so clever
anyway
so it's not a two-day thing it's not a
3D thing it's not 4D it's
1536 dimensions and that's called a
vector and then this then it uses cosine
which you might remember from high
school but it finds uh area it finds
stuff in similarity groups now
for example see this term here this is
really on our rules it's daily scrum it
breaks that up into
1500 of these numbers okay and they will
be the vector and they will go into a
database so you've got to pre-generate
all your vectors which we did for all
the rules and then you compare them and
by the way I generated this image too
there's another another image
visualizing
um embeddings
so then we took that 1500
concept and ran a python library that
flattens it out and that is where that
rule sits that rule email sender V2 sits
right here and the rules around it are
going to be similarly talking about
fixing mistakes and stuff
so there's the python Library if you
want it
but if you look for scrum guide here's
another one see all the red that means
very close to that term so there's a
whole bunch of rules that keep referring
to scrum
Isn't that cool
so that's going to be your internet now
these embeddings can be used for
disorganized documents where you can
group them to technology Entertainment
Sports these are used for Google it
groups all these things in a similar
Manner and there's uh put an article
here so you can read about how it does
it
when you're using Netflix and you look
down here and you say because you watch
narcos if you watch narcos it recommends
this the same type of concept all this
embeddings concept I found this
fascinating now unlike you guys I don't
speak a second language
but and but or three four yes I saw this
um Norwegian and Swede talking earlier
today just chatting to each other and
said how much do you understand about 90
and they're very happy amazing I didn't
realize
so um this four
and that the Chinese character or
whatever they all sit together so they
all uh sit in there uh in their Vector
in the same area so it's going to be
awesome for you know translations and
stuff and obviously you know about
embeddings because you use chat GPT okay
now let's talk about the database how
many people have used a vector database
yeah
four okay not many so you're not going
to use SQL server for this job okay
unless you want it to be really slow
now these Vector databases have cosine
similarity built in there's pine cone
milvas postgres there's there's redis
there's many of these
you can go into SQL server and create a
postgres one and use that
we've tested Super Bass it was very good
but essentially this is what it has in
it it has this vector and this has all
the all the dimensions the 1500
dimensions in here that's what it looks
like and we're going to use that
so we're gonna we're going to integrate
that embeddings database with GPT so
let's have a look at how this works
how do I send a V2 email and you'll get
your answer back okay very nice
now I the next thing you're going to
think about is do I use 3.5
basically free or are you going to use
four now GPT 3.5 it's like a a crappy
fast car okay it will give you an answer
and it's decent and you might be very
happy because it's pretty good but if
you use if you do the exact same thing
and you're prepared to spend some
dollars with GPT you'll see it will give
you a link to a video it puts in a nicer
formatting it's a little bit nicer okay
um here's another one what's some you
know let's just imagine an employee was
to ask what how do I use scrum within
the company it would 3.5 will give you a
decent area it'll link off to we have a
rule about eight steps to scrum it will
give some answers here if you ask the
same thing here you know remember when
we told it to be funny
uh gpt4 seems funnier if that's
important to you okay and the answers
have a little bit more humor in all of
them
now what if I search this like obviously
no engineer should type this on out on
our Corpus of data show me the rules to
better woodworking
PT 3.5 is an alpha liar
it just makes up crap we don't have any
rule rules to better woodworking
I don't know
yes we are about to for
for why am I not doing anything
so show me the rules to better
woodworking it says look sorry about
that we don't have any rules about
woodworking but hey you know Safety
First keep your workspace clean measured
twice cut once blah blah blah okay
so it's a much better answer if you
really care about this
all right
now uh it also like you know draft an
email for a colleague to change some
content because their profile is wrong
it made up a wrong URL here so it's
annoying
okay maybe we're going to be forced to
use for
and this is the better answer for the
same question
and it says Hey and it drops up the
actual email here's the subject here's
the body you should use
you know Etc
all right
now if if you would like you can now go
in and try this you
um I will just jump to it
so you're going to here
and we have a little
this this was the old way so people
would click on these and browse through
here Etc now we have
is is it obvious to you the UI to get to
chat GPT
who can see it
oh less than 10 uh all right this this
UI is not Norwegian friendly obviously
but over here is the rules GPT mode so
now this is the new experience of using
it
so I can come in here and I can say I
don't know V2 email
and it will go off and use and give me
an answer hopefully it will look in our
Corpus of rules and give me something
hey oh hi there see it's funny oh hey
there so you're wondering about this as
well sometimes you need a new version
here's the rule blah blah blah now I
want you to see
um
we we put this dark and light mode
because we know in Norway sometimes
you're either all dark or all light so
you might need that
now we also this is how you're going to
have to handle the key I don't know how
you want to do it but you can use the
the default one which is 3.5 which
you'll probably offer to all your users
and inside your company you might make a
decision that your Corpus of data should
be always on for because you want a good
okay
and I've given some commentary here so
it's very clear
or you might want to just use your your
own key because you
sources
okay
um so yeah so if I you can see that's
the answer there but if I was just to
switch that key to four
oh yes I'd have to go and get the key
now
um
then you'd get a better answer
all right so
under the covers
they're typing a prompt
the API is looking up the embeddings
database it is finding what you just
searched for and then it's finding the
rules around that or the documents in
your case around that updating the
system prompt sending the user message
with the system prompt to the API to the
chat GPT API and then that app that you
just saw that's a Blazer app okay
because we like C sharp so we didn't
Blazer and that's pretty much how it
works now I want you to think about
something
that's probably two developers two weeks
like is that reasonable like you've seen
what you have to do it's not that bad we
can give you the code so you probably do
it faster but for us it took two
developers two weeks say 200 bucks an
hour
or maybe
you have to reduce it now because you
don't have any rich people to pay you
um
but that's about in our ballpark in
Australia and then you've got to focus
on the ongoing costs okay the the API
costs now that's about 40 bucks a month
just for us now
in fact I will give you the real numbers
because this one is tricky now for us
every single employee in our company is
using this okay
um
now I kind of when when you're going
into a very large company uh you
understand this is gonna there's a lot
of people here I don't know how many
sessions ever they charge this based on
a session there's a big document on what
sessions are but it's essentially a
conversation so you jump jump in it's
like picking up the phone we'll have a
conversation you put it down that's the
end that's the charge right so the way
we did it is okay so we've got a hundred
employees this we hope that they'll be
using it twice a day that's how that's
two
200 um
and there's 20 days in a month okay so 4
000 sessions I think we're gonna have to
estimate for okay now
that was our costs for the last month
seven bucks this is not very realistic
by the way this is going to get and
don't forget
um if this was four
and we weren't scummy and we gave more
four that'd be times 30. it gets a lot
more expensive
now I don't like talking about cost
because all these costs are pretty
flimsy but I want you to know about it
okay now I want you to know there is
another way of doing this
I call this the Viking option right
this isn't for everyone but you know
what are Vikings like they're very
productive they like a lot of gold and
Mead
and women but we ain't talk about that
there is an option that was released two
days ago
at the build conference it's called
Microsoft power virtual agents or
Microsoft pvas okay it's not as good as
like power bi is it they could it should
have just caught a power bots or
something
but
this is something you might want to get
your head around okay this is the
productivity mode
there's a great video here I will let
you play it at your own convenience
but you come in here and this is what
you do you click on create bot
and when we tried it this was here but
today this button disappeared and went
into here so this is now done so that
one is now changed it's now over there
it's no longer a preview it's the thing
so you come in here and you give it a
name and then you give it your Corpus of
data in our case for me it was the rules
we did this we used this and it was
super cool now you the example that they
have is they're giving three corpuses of
data here so a public website
um a a OneDrive thing from the company
and a SharePoint thing from the company
so that's their intranet and all their
document Library throw it all together
and you're instantly asking questions I
couldn't believe it you can ask
questions straight away and you are
getting these answers after all that
work we did all right
sometimes now I do want you to
understand
marks have been working on this for
obviously sometime well before GPT I
guess okay they've had this product for
a while but it wasn't working in this
mode that I'm showing you it in now
essentially if you look at it carefully
it just gets the question and then gives
you the answer the link it's not as
free-flowing as the big answers I was
giving you using chat GPT right
um
or using the GPT service now
that was working if you if you want it
to work better let's just say people are
asking about say the weather like you're
uh you're selling tickets and they go oh
I want to go to the Canary Islands and
um I hope the weather next week is good
blah blah blah they you go oh they keep
asking about the weather we'll have to
put an extra plug in here for the
weather and then you put that in and
then you put in your premise you can see
a knowledge worker can do this you're
not actually dealing with an API this is
pretty bloody good
uh now I did want to warn you because
some of you might have seen the old
version of the pvas and they they were
using Lewis and they were using Azure
bot service and there was a lot of
complexity so if you have this in your
head this is gone this doesn't exist
anymore okay as of two days ago
this is the UI that you get now and when
you're trying to work out what it's
doing you know they ask hey what minute
what last minute cruise options do you
have to the Bahamas and what's the
weather like well since we've put the
the plug-in for weather it will answer
well that's the weather I can answer
that bit and the other stuff oh I'm
missing where are you going from so
we'll say hey where are you departing
from see how clever it is and then it
will answer that part of the question
so
does anyone remember this the query
execution plants how many old people do
we have okay half the room wow
that's amazing so they don't have this
but they had something that reminded me
of that they have this thing called
tracing mode and when you ask this and
you want to know exactly what it was
doing it has a trace mode they should
change that to query execution plan mode
shouldn't they then we'd all know and
then you get all this so you can see
what it's doing and you can't do that
much but you can see what's happening so
you could add more plugins and try to
help it now I don't know we we actually
got this going in an hour if that but
I'm going to say you've got to talk to a
product owner and explain to them and
you know have coffee and stuff so I'm
putting two developers two days
so 200 an hour
or low code these are low code people
you could probably cut that to 50 bucks
an hour okay
um
so six thousand dollars now the ongoing
cost this is where things get fuzzy
because we don't know all the costs and
it's very hard to estimate the number of
conversations or sessions that you're
going to use
but I'm telling you that based on this
link on their site that it looks like
it's 200
um a month that's what it looks like for
2 000 sessions if you remember I did my
calculation that would do that would do
fine for ssw for us
now they also mentioned that there is
now a GPT mode so that is not using GPT
if you want the big nice answers and all
that stuff then you're going to have to
pay the GPT Edition they have not told
us what that's going to cost but you
know how much the open AI is charging so
you can kind of guess what what they're
going to charge and it looks like
um
it looks like that GPT Edition is going
to be two grand a month that's heavy
right
yes
well before that would have been nothing
for you guys but that's heavy now
so when you talk to your bosses you have
to make this decision I guess here's my
I'm choosing an arbitrary three years I
don't know how you make this cost
benefit analysis but three years
I'm saying the initial development is
32k and 8K a year for development
maintenance because you need well that's
that's that's that answer is BS really
because as soon as there's an API change
because this is very early days we'll be
fixing it as soon as gpt5 comes out
we'll be fixing it and obviously in this
one there'll be no fixing because every
time there's a change Microsoft they're
going to do it for you
um
the this is like cheap because where
you know we're just using App service
and open AI this one it looks like
they're going to be charging you
something like this if you get the GPT
Edition then you can add on so if you
don't want if you're happy with what I
showed you in the beginning that's going
to be 20 grand if you want GPT I don't
know but it's going to be more expensive
and substantially more expensive if you
want four
all right gpt4 is not going to be cheap
so something like this if you get gpt4
for this it's something similar all
these numbers don't take them take them
with the grain of salt but I wanted to
give you
um the pros and cons because my session
was complete I just looked at that
presentation from Microsoft and go wow
that's out of control productive
so we got a lot done higher Roi low
effort all right
and the best thing is that Viking
developer doesn't need to know about
hosting the API tokens temperature or
the playground they're just going to use
that PVA studio and worry about adding
plugins really and and doing that
execution mode they don't need to know
about embeddings vectors and you know
Vector databases none of that stuff
things are really nice so I have a
question for you
the custom one is obviously big upfront
cost
this is the custom not not the Viking
option the custom one it's got a monthly
cost it's difficult to learn and then
you've got to maintain it but you can do
whatever you want lots of freedom I like
Freedom you know I like doing things as
a developer you got the PVA very minimal
up front
it is if you ask me not difficult at all
nothing to maintain like I should even
delete that little man
it's clearly going to be more mainstream
because most big companies are just
going to go with it
who prefers like if you had to make this
for your company would you prefer the
custom mode
or
so can I just check how many people use
the custom mode
I have
15 of the room
how many people would go the PVA route
I think it's about 60 of the room all
right it's hard to tell but
um yeah so look who knows
so this is my thought if you don't like
the monthly costs because the PVA might
have monthly costs that are hard to
sustain you can still use the pvas just
to build your your prototype quick put
it in check it and then you could build
your custom solution and pay you know
pay that way if you need it but I don't
know it's going to be interesting so
let's talk about the future the last
little bit
what's the future because there's a lot
of talk you know about what you know
we're we're heading to artificial
general intelligence there's going to be
zero impact required to do stuff you
tell AI to write you a book and it will
write you a book okay we haven't had one
that people buy yet but you can do it
you can tell it to develop a full
software application
and it will do it okay almost
so
there are these other companies all
doing the same stuff Google meta and IBM
are all competing against open AI open
AI is clearly the leader there is one
company we have an office uh
in China and that company to think about
is 10 cent there's quite a few doing a
lot of AI in China but that's uh
certainly worth uh noticing one of these
companies could surpass
uh open AI
now I want you to just be aware of this
Auto GPT it you can give it a broad task
and it will uh build a website that
sells shoes it will break all the tasks
down execute each task combine the
results so
this is the future it's going to be able
to write code clone push the PRS accept
the PR's uh
build and test have a bug fix it itself
write its own output that becomes the
input something like this you have a
developer defining a PBI
in fact you don't need to developer you
can just get the product owner or the
CEO could sack the product owner and get
rid of the developers and from
Switzerland he is just going to
so they're going to
um put their PBIS in the agent is going
to pick up the the task break that down
if it doesn't know what to do ask
questions back you're going to answer it
it will write that code clone it push it
create the pr and look clearly it's
going to be like a two-headed monster
that comes back if you don't have
developers reviewing the code the pull
requests and keeping monitoring of this
so it's there but this is pretty close
to where you're at
Sam Altman had this quote so I thought
I'd put it in I think we're at the end
of the year where it's going to be these
like giant giant models
imagine Winston Churchill having like in
his big statements
um but he's basically saying there's big
models like Bart and you know the GPT
service and
we're more likely going to be making all
these small AIS that we're going to use
for different things
um you know you might get an x-ray and
then you'll be using some x-ray uh you
know a Ai and it will Analyze That and
tell you a lot more than what say a
radiographer could do
I'm going to ask you if you'd like to if
you've got that app installed inside the
app you can scan this and get a thousand
points
I'll give you a summary so we talked
through all the all the news and
obviously the office product which was
already pretty phenomenal compared with
the Google products now have all this AI
stuff they got real lucky with this deal
uh office and I told you about the data
products are phenomenal you now know how
important it is to be a great prompt
engineer
you now know what the server does the
service does a lot you know about
embeddings and Vector databases and how
cool that bot is broadly this is the
most powerful API you will ever use AI
can pretty much do everything
so this will be the last NDC
we'll be coming back for the woodworking
Conference next year
um
but look honestly this is the most
exciting
uh period that I have ever been in I
think it's going to be an incredible uh
incredible time uh I have these
a whole bunch of these so you can come
up and grab them if you like put put
them on your toilets all throughout
Norway
and thank you very much
foreign